bonjour claude bonjour emmanuel macron
qu'ils rencontrent olaf scholz ce soir à
berlin il va être évidemment question de
l'ukraine quels sont les enjeux de cette
visite cette visite tombe très bien elle
était prévue de longue date puisque
macron rend la visite que la seule qui
avait fait à paris le 10 janvier est
donc effectivement ils vont parler
naturellement de la présidence française
avec les priorités de la présidence
française
le numérique faire un marché comme un
peu numériques qui soient vraiment
autonomes mais aussi les investissements
mais aussi l'immigration mais aussi les
sujets sur lesquels ils sont pas du même
avis par exemple sur la classification
des dépenses d'investissement dans le
nucléaire et puis bien sûr ils vont
aussi parler de l'actualité la plus
chaude la guerre ou la paix c'est à dire
de la situation en ukraine et puis il se
trouve que l'allemagne préside cette
année le g7 dont le sommet aura lieu fin
juin mais entre temps il ya des réunions
au niveau des ministres et par
conséquent ils auront beaucoup de choses
à discuter c'est donc le début d'une une
coordination sans doute très étroite
entre le nouveau chancelier allemand et
emmanuel macron sachant que la coalition
du chancelier allemand est évidemment
amène des forces nouvelles puisque les
verts sont francs font partie et que les
verts ont des positions tout à fait
particulière sur un certain nombre de
sujets et notamment sur l'énergie aie et
que vont sur le craignent justement que
vont pouvoir se dire les deux chefs
d'état
je pense que ils vont chercher à réduire
les la difficulté sur les sujets sur
lesquels il ya des divergences par
exemple sur l'énergie la france attache
beaucoup d'importance à ce que les
investissements énergétiques soit classé
comme important pour la transition pour
décarbonés l'économie alors que la
coalition allemande évidemment est d'un
avis différent il ya une majorité à
bruxelles pour approuver la proposition
de la commission qui est en effet de
classer l'énergie nucléaire est aussi le
gaz dans les énergies nécessaires à la
transition de décarbonation
l'allemagne a besoin de ce gaz parce que
elle a déjà décidé de supprimer toute
l'énergie nucléaire et la dernière
centrale va être déclassé cette année en
22 en 2022 et par conséquent il faut
bien remplacer se veut clair par
quelques chaussée ou charbon prouve le
gaz charbon c'est pire que tout puisque
c'est ce qui émet le plus de co2 par
conséquent là dessus il ya probablement
des possibilités de s'entendre pour le
reste il ya beaucoup de convergences
entre l'allemagne et la france et il ya
surtout des habitudes de travail en
commun à tous les niveaux parce qu'il ya
pas que le sommet est allé niveau
ministériel il ya beaucoup de rencontres
au niveau des ministres ne serait ce que
pour préparer les conseils formels et
informels qui vont avoir lieu dans les
mois qui suivent sous la présidence
française et puis sur les sujets qui
seront discutés à bruxelles parce que
finalement c'est ça l'histoire de la
deûle à proximité
franco-allemande c'est que spontanément
on n'a pas nécessairement les mêmes
intérêts spontanément on n'est pas
d'accord mais on a décidé une fois pour
toutes de s'asseoir et discuter ensemble
jusqu'à ce qu'on soit d'accord sur les
différents sujets absolument alors donc
sur sur l'ukraine qu'est ce qu'ils vont
pouvoir se dire vous parlez du gaz il ya
aussi le fameux gazoduc nord stream
d'eau qui est qui est en jeu alors
l'urgence c'est de se mettre d'accord
sur la désescalade puisque en effet
les manoeuvres russe aux frontières de
l'ukraine qui avait essentiellement pour
objet de dissuader un ski de faire une
opération militaire sur rien jeu sur
lozon basse le président de l'unss qui
est ukrainien bien sûr de faire une
opération militaire si d'aventuré il en
avait eu l'idée mais on lui a prêté sept
7 cette idée parce que en effet les
forces ukrainiennes se sont renforcés
considérablement depuis
1015 depuis sept ans et que par
conséquent il peut avoir cette envie
mais il a été élu sur un programme qui
était un programme de rétablissement de
la paix et la grande nouvelle
aujourd'hui et qui est tombée hier en
effet c'est que demain il y aura à paris
une réunion en format normandie
naturellement pas un sommet il faut
préparer un éventuel sommet ça sera au
niveau des conseillers diplomatiques des
chefs d'état de gouvernement du format
normandie et pour la russie ce sera
monsieur dmitri kozak qui passe pour
être quelqu'un très pragmatique et que
par ailleurs avec qui j'ai eu l'occasion
de travailler lorsque j'étais
ambassadeur en russie il ya un certain
nombre d'années sur d'autres sujets
bah oui alors il faut effectivement que
à l'intérieur du format normandie
l'ukraine accepte d'appliquer le schéma
des accords de minsk de l'appliquer
complètement c'est difficile pour
monsieur et masse qui sait pas ce que ça
veut dire accorder une certaine
autonomie à l'intérieur des frontières
de l'ukraine au combat c'est à dire aux
aux provinces que de louhansk et de
donetsk c'est donc très difficile
politiquement parce qu'il sera accusé de
trahison bien sûr mais je pense qu'il
faut le faire parce que les russes ne
cherche pas évidemment envers l'ukraine
mais veulent absolument que ces deux
provinces soit autonome à l'intérieur de
l'état ukrainien peut-être aussi pour en
effet
empêcher l'adhésion ultérieure de
l'ukraine un jour à l'otan ce que
d'ailleurs peu de gens sont pressés de
voir se produire parce que à part le
secrétaire général de l'otan qui en
parlent tout le temps il n'est pas sûr
que beaucoup de pays est envie de voir
le cren entrée dans l'otan tout de suite
dé d'ailleurs il en est de même pour la
géorgie qui tannait à 10 visés puisque
en géorgie il ya deux républiques
autoproclamées qui ne sont pas contrôlés
par le centre donc par ailleurs pour
dénouer le le noeud gordien de cette
crise est bien évidemment doit se
poursuivre une négociation qui a déjà
été entamées entre moscou et washington
sur l'âme ce contrôle en matière de
fusée en matière mme d'armes nucléaires
ça ne concerne que les états unis et que
la russie est en effet la russie
légitimement voudrait négocier le
positionnement européen des fusées
nucléaires américaines en évitant que
ces fusées puisse être positionné un
jour dans des pétards frontières de la
russie merci beaucoup claude pour toutes
ces explications s'était elle évite aux
diplômes de la matinale ce matin